it's not very many people really know
but the great lakes has thousands of
shipwrecks
in wisconsin for sure we know we have
750
historic shipwreck losses
my name is caitlin zandt and i'm a
maritime archaeologist with the
wisconsin historical society
i would say the main goal of what we do
in maritime archaeology is to preserve
our maritime history and also the
history of the united states in general
the ships are quite sturdy but they've
also been underwater for
up to 100 150 years
our shipwrecks don't disappear over time
like they do in the oceans the fresh
water that's very cold actually does a
really good job at preserving these
shipwrecks
one of the really great things about
lake michigan that makes it really
unique is the fact that you do have
fresh clear water you can see many times
especially on deep wrecks 100 to 150
feet
when you were down there looking at a
shipwreck you start to think of all the
sailors that sailed on it or if it was a
passenger ship the passengers that
happened to be on it
you can still find pieces of
clothing in certain areas buttons shoes
and so that really gives insight to the
lives of these sailors
there's definitely a little bit of a
thrill of discovery um when we go down
on a ship even on a ship that we know we
think we know what it is there's still
always that little
sense of excitement that you're going to
find something that no one else has seen
before
we're an off-site facility of the
natural history museum that's not open
to the public this is the skull of
humpback whale our collection of marie
mammals is the second largest collection
in north america this hole right here is
where the eye would have been when it
was still alive we have approximately 5
000 specimens and that includes
dolphins whales seals sea lions i
consider myself the current steward of
the collection
i think of the term
whale warehouse as kind of endearing
when people come to the warehouse
definitely
i think the first thing that is noticed
is the smell
it has a musty museum smell but
because of the marine mammals having a
lot of oils and lipids there's
definitely a smell of rancid oils we
have jars filled with various kinds of
specimens oh yeah this is nice these are
eyeballs
most people i've worn in advance that
you know this is what you need to
understand the place is like you know
it's not tourist attraction
the warehouse has several different
functions and and one
is to serve as a storage facility for
the oversized specimens
but it's also the facility where we
actually prepare new specimens
we're part of the national marine mammal
stranding network
we respond to dead stranded marine
mammals
and most of what we've learned about
these species is a result of studying
them closely
we have specimens that have been around
for decades or even more
the collection really is of
international significance if you're a
marine mammal researcher and you've
probably been here
some of the recent research
includes things like global climate
processes and and how that has changed
over time
i'm a scientist and i'm a little bit
removed from the emotional aspect of
things but i still appreciate the
majesty of these incredibly large
charismatic animals and it's it's
difficult to
not be affected um emotionally
by the kinds of things that we're
studying animals that are on the verge
of extinction
what are we going to do about
pop that you need some info on the
futolankosaurus the barosuchus and the
daisynodon where do you go wikipedia
thanks nobumiji oh no problem how do we
know what these prehistoric creatures
look like
lots of careful research and attention
to details
how do you know i draw them wait really
all of them well a lot of them
this is nobumiji tamura hello and he's
got a pretty cool day job i'm working at
the advanced light source lawrence
berkeley national laboratory and my job
here is to take care of this machine
this micro diffraction and station the
micro defrag what micro diffraction and
station ah
but it's at night and on weekends that
nobu channels the scientific know-how
into his dinosaur drawings it's called
paleoart
my bad
paleoart is an original artistic
creation that depicts prehistoric life
according to the latest research right
nobu exactly it's a combination of
science and creativity so i basically
read the latest discovery on prehistoric
animals based on that i draw them this
is what i've been doing for the last
eight years and nibble's got a lot to
show for it by his estimate he's
published over 1500 drawings including
some in this book that he co-authored
but it wasn't always smooth sailing the
first drawing that was one of a dinosaur
called cosmosaurus but it was taken out
by the editors because it wasn't
accurate enough
that's okay nobu can't bat a thousand is
that the baseball reference i'm french
i got it not every baguette can be
perfect well done here wait wait come
back come back come back
no they're never just bones
it's all part of history it's all part
of the world's history
majority of people don't know we're here
the facility it's custom made to build
dinosaurs
my name is peter may and i build
dinosaur skeletons for museums
throughout the world
i'm the owner president of research
casting international we have 50 000
square feet we can handle the biggest
skeletons in the world
t-rex mastodons
allosaurs
we've mounted and displayed and built
right around 800 skeletons
in our back room we have 50 skeletons
sitting in crates
when the skeleton arrives it'll be
uncreated unpacked and then it'll go
into the conservation department it'll
be cleaned and hardened and any of the
old consolidates removed so it's nice
and strong
it comes to blacksmiths they hammer out
the armatures once all the armatures are
done then we go to mounting
all in all they'll probably be about a
crew of 10 that'll handle the fossils
there's a car i saw the skeleton crew
we're doing a pair of skeletons right
now the driptasaurs and they're probably
one of the most dynamic poses you'll
ever see there's two dryptosaurs like
leaping in the air one on his back one
leaping down on top of it
we built the two big skeletons in the
first movie jurassic park the the
rearing barissart the american museum of
natural history
for the smithsonian we're helping them
rebuild all their exhibits all the
fossil animal exhibits
our job is to bring the old skeletons to
life
i think when fossils arrive here we
become the caretaker nothing can happen
to it and every person is handled along
the way understands that responsibility
by the time it's finished it comes out a
much better
fossil than when it arrived when it goes
on exhibit at the museum it's going to
last for another 100 years
foreign
is
you